now you've got your chance to use this
scale to figure out how much something
weighs so we're asked how much does Old
Spice man way we have Old Spice man this
little this little guy here plus you
have three blocks so on the left hand
side you have Old Spice man plus three
blocks and you see that the scale is
balanced on the right hand side you have
eight blocks so Old Spice man plus three
is equal to eight blocks and you can see
what happens when we do something to one
side of the scale or another if we were
to take a block from the right-hand side
all of a sudden the right-hand side
becomes lighter and it tilts up and our
scale is no longer balanced and we can
no longer say that the left and the
right-hand side is equal and there's an
explanation of it below here so we want
to do is add or remove blocks from the
left or right hand side so essentially
we're just left with Old Spice man on
the left hand side but the scale is
balanced so whatever is on the right
hand side is how much he weighs in
blocks so let's see if we can do that so
let me let me add that block back that's
where we started from so let's see I
want to get rid of these three so if I
take 1 away from the left-hand side well
I can't just do it there because now all
of a sudden the left-hand sides too
light so I'm going to have to take one
away from the right-hand side as well
and well let me do it again take 1 away
from the left-hand side we'll have to do
one from the right-hand side as well and
I'm getting close one from the left-hand
side now one from the right-hand side
and it is balanced Old Spice man is
equal to five blocks and you see what
happened here algebraically I took one
from the left and right-hand side I did
it three times so I started with
essentially Old Spice man or you could
call it X plus three but then we ended
up subtracting three from the left hand
side and subtracting three from the
right hand side so we subtracted the
same number from both sides to get the
weight of Old Spice man and we could
check it right over here and very good